projet kucci bonjour vous étiez jusqu'à
aujourd'hui premier vice-président du
Sénat va y avoir maintenant un nouveau
bureau du Sénat qui va être élu dans les
prochains jours un mot sur ce qui va se
jouer dans la séance qui commence à 15h
il y a pas beaucoup de suspense Gérard
Larchet devrait être élu président du
Sénat vous le croyez
je ne crois pas j'en suis sûr il sera
réélu président du Sénat dès le premier
tour puisque évidemment il a le soutien
du groupe des Républicains du groupe
Union centriste des indépendants bon
voilà donc a priori il peut compter sur
230 voix sur 348 dès le premier tour
donc il sera élu dès le premier tour 5è
mandat à la présidence du Sénat
qu'est-ce qu'il représente selon vous
j'aicher dans le paysage politique
actuel il a réussi à faire en sorte que
plus personne ne dise que le Sénat est
une anomalie démocratique que plus
personne ne dise le Sénat ça ne sert à
rien il faut le dissoudre ou le faire
disparaître et donc il a réussi
conforter c'est vrai par le fait qu'il
n'y a pas de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale mais il a réussi
dans le débat avec les exécutif à
apparaître comme le véritable
interlocuteur du gouvernement et à faire
du Sénat la chambre dans laquelle on
travaille sur le fond des textes dans la
mesure du possible en première lecture
de manière à faire de bons textes de loi
qu'on envoie ensuite à l'Assemblée
quelle doit être la position politique
de la majorité de la droite et du centre
vous le disiez un interlocuteur
privilégié pour l'exécutif certes mais
faut-il être davantage constructif avec
cette majorité ou faut-il être aussi une
chambre qui peut être une chambre
d'opposition face à l'exécutif quel est
votre avis vous sur le suj mais en vrai
les
deux